all right so hello everyone a very warm
greeting to one and all uh we'll be
starting with the webinar in just a few
more minutes and meanwhile we are
waiting it would be great if the
participants can introduce yourself in
the chat box uh let us know from um what
is your education background
foreign
I hope I'm pronouncing your name correct
otherwise please feel free to correct me
and he says he is from uh MSC computer
science that's pretty interesting uh can
you also let us know what made you
interested to learn about uh fine math
your transition from computer science to
mind
and we also have Maureen she is
um an MSC bioinformatics and molecular
biology student from Kenya yes Maury
Hello nice to meet you
and um
Sadiq is uh pursuing
and master of Engineering in information
and electronics engineering we do have a
nice range of students amongst us I'm
curious to know about
your transition as well what made you
interested to learn about bioinformatics
let us know in the chat
all right I can see the few more
participants have joined and a few of
our research fellows have also joined so
just to give you an overview in today's
webinar we will just be introducing the
participants to the research fellowship
program and we are also joined by our
former research fellows who will be
presenting their project and it's going
to be an interactive session where you
can ask queries about the program and
learn more about
and we do have a couple of responses in
the chat uh since it says he wants to
help fight complex diseases like cancer
which is computational skill that is
pretty uh inspiring and Maureen says the
ability to be able to analyze genetic
makeup of an organism to understand the
reason why and give solution to an
existing phenomena that's also pretty
interesting to know thank you so much
Maureen Anthony
has also shared uh currently he is
working in anti-cancer peptide
classification using a computational
model but he's not sufficient about this
and is working on generating an
anti-cancer peptides using a generative
adversial Network so here comes a bridge
to learn molecular mechanism of peptide
to different cancer cells and besides
this I also want to learn molecular
talking all right thank you so much for
that
uh description
do you
um
have you also like learned about the
research fellowship program or are you
new to this
Maureen I know uh you are already a
research fellow with us
uh what about the rest of you sadik and
seasick
all right season
um he has already signed up for the
program yes I just got to know about
that and Sadiq uh he is working at John
book National University as a researcher
all right thank you so much everyone for
introducing yourself and letting us know
about your research interests and
meanwhile the participants rest of the
participants can also let us know um
about your educational background and
research interest and in the meantime uh
other participants will be joining us
and without further delay let's start
with today's webinar so hello everyone a
very warm greeting for one and on my
name is
and I would like to welcome you all for
the webinar on omixlogic bindsmatics and
data science research fellowship program
so those of you who are joining us for
the very first time the research
fellowship program has been designed to
help young researchers and students take
advantage of the bi-in-thematic
resources for the analysis of complex
life science data and become well versed
in buy and food research fellows
participate in cutting-edge by
informatics research led by expert
mentors and the fellowship program will
offer a combination of online resources
and mental guidance
to prepare you and help you complete a
bioinformatics project
so before we begin with today's webinar
let me always take a brief moment to
introduce you to the team behind the
program we are a us-based bioinformatics
company who is working with multiple
academic and Commercial collaborators to
develop easy to use analytical tools and
our mission is to make buy informatics
more accessible
and as a part of our mission our team is
working with local and Regional
coordinators that are helping refine
local program Logistics and adapting
them to the needs of students and
researchers around the world and this
training has been completed by over 24
000 participants from 187 countries in
over 300 workshops and in different
specialization practices that includes
oncology infectious diseases Precision
medicine neuroscience and data
and as a part of the training you will
have access to the omic storage
resources which takes a combination of
training modules data analysis tools
curated project data sets and
interactive sessions with mentors to
give the student a clear part of the
Bloom's taxonomy print
and this also comes with an access to
the omics courses which includes courses
on bioinformatics Precision medicine
multi-amines that consists of genomics
transcriptomics metagenomics and
epigenomics data science that makes use
of bioinformatics using RN python as
well as chem informatics and example
projects of different fields which you
could learn from and replicate for your
research work the omics larger platform
also gives options for analyzing a given
data set and these data sets and
Associated public Nations can be used in
several ways that is you can learn
bioinformatics without any coding at all
and for those interested in opting the
non-code pathway they will be given
directions to access the key by info
platform for bioinformatic processing
and Analysis of data the platform
includes demo pipelines as well as data
management and Analysis drug
infrastructure to run the bioinformatic
pipeline and different stages of
analysis are performed in different
sections on this multi-atomics platform
and for those interested in learning to
analyze data through coding we provide
the omic storage core playground which
will help you develop coding skills
while learning popular packages in our
programming and python to visualize
annotate and analyze complex patterns in
biological data
so now to view the various courses
example projects including projects you
need to first sign up on the Onyx
logical and portal so let me walk you
through on how you can do that
so those of you who have not signed up
on the portal I'm sharing the link for
signing up in the chat box
please visit the link and I'll walk you
through on how you can sign
so if you're signing up for the very
first time uh when you visit the link
you'll be able to see the create an
account option click on that
and when you click on that you will be
able to create an account by entering
your name providing an email and a
password or you can also sign up using
any of your social media handles it
could be your Google account Facebook
account Apple account GitHub account or
even Twitter and for those participants
who have already an account on the
portal we can simply click on the login
now option and simply enter the existing
email ID and password and just sign so
that was all about how you can sign up
and with that I'll pause for a couple of
seconds for the various pins to sign up
and once you have please let me know in
the chat and I'll proceed
if you already have an existing account
on the potent you can put a done in the
chat box so that I know you're good to
go
foreign
technical issues you can let us know
that as well in the chat box and we'll
be happy to look into it
all right we do have a couple of
responses in the chat that they have
signed up
[Music]
yeah
all right since uh I can see that some
of you have already signed up so I'm
just going to proceed ahead but along
the way if you're having any queries you
can let us know and we'll be happy to
help so since I already have an account
on the portal I'm just going to click on
sign in
and once you sign in the very first page
that you will be seeing is the courses
tab so under the courses page when you
scroll down below you will see a search
bar that is looking for a specific
course so here if you want to enter any
area of your research interest so for
example if you are interested to learn
about transfer comics then that will
show you the various courses and example
projects that makes use of the concept
on transfer prompt and as you can see
there are several courses uh one on
transport Comics then single cell
transfer Comics then analyzing
Transformers data using our programming
in Python and several other example
projects as well so you can simply enter
any of the keywords that you're
interested to learn more about and it
will show you
so let's say I can say that a few other
parts can be very interested in oncology
when I enter the term oncology it shows
me uh several example projects uh that
one can learn more
so that is all about how you can
navigate the courses page now uh the
very first thing that you have to do
once you sign up is to set up your
account to be able to do that you can
click on the blue bar that is welcome
back with your email ID when you click
on that chart it will directly take you
to your profile settings here you will
see a button that says profile when you
click on that it will enable you to edit
the features uh that you are required to
update on your account so what are these
features first of all make sure that
your name is in proper capitalization
because once you complete the courses
the certificates will be automatically
generated so it is important that your
name is in proper capitalization and the
second thing is to upload a profile
image as well in case you are not
comfortable adding your own image you
can add a University's logo or an avatar
for their profile image and the next
section that you need to update is your
bio wherein you can briefly mention your
educational background and your research
entry and finally after you linked your
social media handles just like in my
case I've linked my LinkedIn account and
my work ID your profile will be complete
annually there to go and now you will
also see several tabs next to your
profile that is your activity tab
wherein the program mentor and the
community manager they will be tracking
your learning progress from this part of
the tab and here under the courses tab
you'll be able to keep a track of all
the courses that you're apparently
completing and it also shows the
coursework progress that you're making
and finally once you complete a research
project and publish it on the portal
you'll be able to get the projects under
the projects tab
finally if you're enrolling for any of
the other programs then you will be able
to see the programs under the programs
Tab and finally once you complete the
required coursework with the associated
assignments and quizzes you will be able
to receive all of the certificates and
other certificates so that was all about
uh I wanted to tell you about setting up
your account now another important tab
that I need to show you is the project
stand as you can see here when you click
on this you can check out all of the
student projects that have been compiled
and put together and all of these are
research project and a lot of them are
presently working on their research
publication or working on post
representation computations and all of
these project topics range from oncology
infectious diseases machine learning
data science phase forming and so on so
the part of students can have a look at
all of these at your own pace there are
tags provided on the right and you can
click on in your view and it will show
you the associated projects that is all
about navigating through the omics.learn
portal and this is the portal that you
will be making yourself as a part of
your program to complete your coursework
and required assigned so that was all
about I wanted to tell you and with that
now I would like to invite our former
research fellows Mr ojaswidaka and
shubham Kumar to present their research
project on effect of microgravity on
human human induced pluripotent stems so
with that the stage is all yours
thank you
hello
I just take a minute to share my screen
I guess shubham has also joined
session
yeah I can see him can you hear me
yes I can hear you
so is my screen visible
it is not in first
yeah and just
yes now we can see your screen thank you
all right so hello all once again so
today I and shubham will be presenting
our research project which we have
completed with buying biotech for our
dissertation
so the title of our project is human
induced pluripotent stem cell derived
cardiomyocytes exhibits late recovery
rate due to stress induced by space
flight and we
completed this in the domain of space
omics using transcriptomics coursework
and introduction to bioinformatics so
I'll just go through once uh
from the introduction starting with
industrial biology and microgravity so
the study of Origins Evolution
distribution and future of life in the
universe is known as astrobiology it is
an interdisciplinary field which Demands
a thorough knowledge of biological
planetary and Cosmic events
microgravity is the most important
influence on the human organism in space
and the human body undergoes dramatic
changes during long term space flight
the long-term exposure of microgravity
by space flight and bed rest on the
ground result in severe osteoporosis and
muscle entropy and neurological
disorders so changing in the structure
and mass of the heart we decided to work
in studying the cardiac functions
cardiacma and lower body vascular
regulation
in this whole research project
so talking about the effects on the
human body by space travel as you can
see this pictorial representation the
human body is uh adversely affected by
microgravity in all terms like in veins
platelets brain radiation also causes
harm to DNA and muscle loss muscle
strength and also it affects the cardiac
related functions
so what is fluidiputin stem cell human
stem cells including embryonic stem
cells and induced to repudent stem cells
have the capability to self-renew
indefinitely and to differentiate into
derivatives of the three germ layers
ectoderm visual Dome and endoderm in
2006 the first induced Philippine stem
cell were generated by reprogramming
skin cells
also they are derived from somatic cells
and has enabled the development of
personalized medical strategies and
patient specific
disease models
stem cells have the ability to like self
uh generate or renew themselves so that
is why uh they can be differentiated
from art to many other
related functions in the human body
so in this project we use these steps as
a method for completing the
research first was to retrieve the data
set from ncbi Geo then we did the Gene
quantification and normalization of raw
data the third step was to do principal
component analysis which is an
unsupervised machine learning analysis
then we did the differential gene
expression analysis followed by again
and Geo pathway analysis and then we did
some manual creation for cardiac and
muscle related activities to find the
major genes and Pathways which are
causing the
harm to the cardic related machine
functionality in human
so this is our GE USS number for the
data set which we have used for our
study the title of the study is effects
of space flight on human induced
preparing stem cell derived
cardiomyocyte structure and function
so in this study the authors try to
maintain the study on the contractility
of muscles and they did some study on
cardiac related uh
muscle pathway analysis as well but
somewhat they like
put more efficient analysis on the
cardiac muscle contractility and
metabolic related Pathways so
the microgravities as we know that it
induces specialized cells and stem cells
the
space flight condition so we decided to
work further on the human cardiac and
muscle activity and
in couple of studies it was discovered
that induced to represent stem cells
transformed into cardiomyocytes May
restore the contractility of the heart
and the researcher decided to replicate
the recent work on mice using human
induced periprint stem cells it was
primarily focused on the impact of
calcium handling and the impact of heart
contractility and then we decided to
further on this uh heart related
analysis so this is the pictorial
representation of the Geo data set page
and Sample characteristics the whole
study was done in the period of 5.5
weeks where 4.5 weeks the samples were
kept in the microgravity exposure and
then they were kept for a rest period
and for the one week of time
so there are total number of 18 samples
in our data set six each in different
conditions in Flight post flight and
Ground Control conditions we created two
different groups
based on the samples in the data set one
is in Flight versus ground and then post
flight versus ground condition
so as the data was normalized on Geo we
collected the Euro file from SRA and
then accordingly analysis was performed
using different pipelines so we used
rnac analysis quantile normalization
PCA and D6 so what is RNA seek analysis
so RNA seek is a technique that can
examine the quantity quantity and
sequences of RNA in a sample using NGS
it analyzes the transcript term
indicating which of the genes encoded in
our DNA are turned on or off and to what
extent
then we did the quantile normalization
to standardize the data obtained
following Gene quantification because it
had various void spaces and null values
and in the same pipeline we used the PCA
component to visualize the data
so here's the pictorial representation
of our result of PCA
so it denoted that we found that the
clustering of sample 2 and Sample 5 in
the in both the conditions ground versus
flight and ground versus host flight are
same the difference we observed was that
in ground versus post flight condition
this one
due to the microgravity stress the
togetherness of the samples was bit
deviated and as compared to ground
versus fried results so the whole
pictorial representation of this species
states that the samples in all the
uh areas lies and the same function like
G1 G4 G1 G4 and uh in post light B uh
pf3 pf4 pf1 but here you can see that in
Flight condition we only had F1 F4 and
in the above symmetry we had G6 G3 F3
and F6 but here in this
one uh the F2 F5 G2 G5 G2 G5 uh PF P2
and
pf5 samples are deviated
then the flight condition so now I would
like shubham to continue from the DC
analysis part
icular
yeah thank you so much
uh could you confirm if my voice is
audible properly
yes your voice is Audible
all right so hello everyone and thank
you just for such a great explanation so
like moving forward like after the PC
analysis we perform the differential
gene expression to determine the level
of expression that whether they are up
regulated or non-regulated in the cell
so we perform the dsap2 analysis using
the t-band for Server you can see the
pipeline which we have used and the
parameters we have set up for the for
our differential gene expression
analysis
now uh like uh here next we can see that
the
like in the next slide we can see that
the heat map of our data set for the
both the ground versus flight and both
and for the ground versus post flight
condition and we also the togetherness
of the closeness of the sample which we
can observe from here like uh for flight
one and flight 4 as well as for the
ground one and ground for which we have
uh like quite similar with the PCA
results
and uh we along with the dear uh dsac
analysis we did the pathway analysis
using uh keg and du so from that we
found the Dot Plot for The Keg analysis
as you can see on the screen and for the
Geo analysis so these are the dot plots
of it from where we can see that some of
the pathways like ribosome and other
related to the like spysosome and some
of them related to the uh
neurodegenerative diseases but because
these were the uh human induced
cardiomyocytes and the previous study
was done on the cardiac study so we also
focused to study our uh like research
work to be on cardiac and muscle related
activities so when we did that we found
that um for the Geo analysis we found
approximately
591 and for the most flight condition we
found approx 1200 genes so you can see
that the number of genes in the post
right condition that is after the
microgravitals test the number of
Pathways we got they are approximately
doubled so similarly this was observed
in The Keg analysis so as I said that we
performed for the cardiac activities and
for the muscle activity so for the
cardiac you can see that the for the
ground versus flight condition we found
only nine Pathways which were highly
enriched and for the ground versus post
fat we found approximately 66 Pathways
which was around five times then the
flight condition and similarly for the
muscle muscle related Pathways we found
that you can see the numbers like 29
Pathways in Grand versus flight n120 and
47 in post-trad condition but for The
Keg we didn't found any result uh of you
in the flight condition but in the post
right we can see that one
pathway is highly enriched so and based
on that we found that some of on when
comparing all these datas we found two
unique Pathways which were either
suppressed or activated in one of the
conditions either in turn versus flight
or either in ground versus post track
condition so the first unique pathway
which we found was the signaling pathway
regulating the pluripotency of the stem
cells and using the degenerate results
we got to know that these pathways are
somehow responsible for the ingrinal
carcinoma or for various uh like cancers
like stomach carcinoma and malignant
neoplasm of this stomach and the genes
which we which are highly enriched for
these particular Pathways as you can see
on the screen is hoax B1 and fgfr4 and
hand one all these things now like here
you can see the pictorial representation
of the complete signaling pathway
regulating the pluripotency of stem
cells and the genes which are highly
enriched so these genes are present in
the r data set as in our results as well
as the pathways which is uh like
responsible for the stem cell activity
now the second unique pathway which we
found in the uh muscle which we found
related to the muscle activity was
vascular smooth muscle contraction
pathway which was activated after the
microgravity stress so this pathway
might be responsible for the
hypertension or the hyper sensitive
diseases or somehow related to The
Chronic heart failure and the genes
responsible for these pathways are like
ADC by 6 and all that
so here yes you can see the pictorial
representation and you can see that how
some of the genes are responsible like
mlck then cam are responsible for the
pathway functioning now what we found
that authors were focused on the
studying authors of focus on studying
the calcium activity of heart relate or
or the heart relaxation or the
contractility but uh what we found is
that this particular pathway like the
vascular smooth muscle past contraction
was totally dependent upon the calcium
for its functioning
so these were all the unique findings
from our data set and uh from our
research work now coming to the
conclusion part uh what we conclude from
a research work is that the pathways
enriched they are statistically relevant
but not biologically uh relevant because
they were representing the
cardiomyocytes and they are responsible
for the neurodegenerative diseases also
now the another conclusion we made was
the the cardiac Pathways were not
significantly changed in the terms of
inflat in the post flight condition
comparing the gene level and because of
the stress we observe the muscle
contraction like these pathway which we
have observed and one more thing what we
found is that the one week of free rest
for the recovery of cells is not
sufficient for the cells to perform the
like normal function or to get in a
normal state
and in the ground versus flight and in
the ground versus post right uh as we
have obscene in as we have observed on
the uh
plots that the enriched pathways are
doubled in both keg and gaca and the two
unique Pathways which we have found in
our analysis the signaling pathway
regulating the pluripotence of stem
cells was observed in the ground versus
flight condition but was suppressed
after the flight condition that it was
not found in post-flat condition and the
pathway related to the muscle was
activated in the post right condition
because of the stress observed in the
micro gravity conditions
so this was all about a research project
work
thank you
so much
and uh just to uh wrap up the
presentation could you please also let
us know
um you have won the poster presentation
competition twice so do you have any
advice for those partisans who are
interested to join the upcoming
symposium
on how they can ease their posters with
yes so I can just show the posts which
we which we have made for the last
simple question
let me share my screen again
uh can you see
uh no not yet
now
[Music]
it started sharing and then it just
stopped
it says the window is
closed
can you see it now
no the screen is not being shared it
seems
yes now it is showing a started screen
sharing yes now weekends
okay so like for the poster presentation
uh we have just like included all our
major work which we have done and the
unique Pathways like the unique findings
from our project so we uh like we have
captured some of the information from
the introduction the major one uh which
we thought that it is important for the
uh judges and other researchers to
play showcase and then we decided to
keep some of the major methods which we
have used like reset to analysis and
what number of samples we have used and
what group we have created for our
analysis
then we also stated some of the uh
like basic values which we have for the
uh kept for our data to be sorted
accordingly and then in result and the
conclusion part we have kept all the key
findings which we have uh like found in
our all the research work which we did
for this specific project so my
suggestion is to just keep it really
specific to what key findings you have
in your uh analysis and not to provide
any further supplementary data or the
findings which is not relevant or maybe
uh like maybe available in the author's
paper so you just have to give the
unique uh key findings in your
like poster and it should be uh like in
a better representation so that the
people can watch it
um within Naked Eyes so it's like an 84
percentage if I will keep it in 100 then
it will be more visible for
so it is easily
like readable and you can analyze like
what we have
found in our project for it
all right thank you so much for uh
joining with us and sharing your
research work
um so now let me share my screen
so uh so far we discussed about uh one
of the research outcome was that
students participating in poster
presentation competition but apart from
that there are several other outcomes
that we have noticed uh as a part of
students completing the research
fellowship program so let's just explore
all of that one by one
so to begin with most of the students
they are focused on publishing their
research work for instance rupee vaja
she is a biomedical science graduate
student who worked on assessing the
underlying reason for the development of
gray matter relations in multiple
sclerosis patients further she went on
to publish her work in immunogenetics
which is an Open Access Journal that
focuses on genetic research areas of
autoimmune disorders and another
interesting student publication is that
of Subhan today he is a genetic
engineering student and he studied the
effect of malaria vaccine and he tried
to understand the molecular mechanisms
underlying the protection that the
vaccine offers and he carried out all of
this using the transcriptomic data sets
further he went on to publish his work
in genomic and informatics which is an
official Journal of the Korea genome
organization
presently we also have several other
students just like them who are working
on their publication and for instance
she is a biotechnology graduate student
she is working on an oncology related
research project and it tries to
understand the after effects of cancer
treatment in patients and like we are
looking forward to several other
Publications from our current student
further you also have the opportunity to
participate in post-representation
competition just like or just we and
shubham did as a part of the omic
research Symposium to an exciting cash
prizes and this Symposium is an
International Symposium that brings
together
experts from different parts of the
world such as Dr Gareth rubber who's a
staff scientist at Lawrence Livermore
National Laboratory Dr Joseph Moore and
among so many others experts who join as
guest speakers and judges and the
students come forward and they present
their research work to in the
post-presentation competition so that is
another outcome that students have
accepted
and the student projects are not just
limited to graduates and Doctor doctoral
students or faculties obvious issues for
instance a very simple example is that
of Andre Modano Sosa he's a high school
student and who won a neuroscience
project at the region around
international science and engineering
fair to which he won the potamkin prize
and the fourth award in biomedical and
Health Sciences category
and this program can also be integrated
as a part of the existing University
curriculum for instance we offer the
machine learning for biomedical data
course which is integrated into the
systems medicine graduate program at
Georgetown University and this resulted
in students completing their research
project on a diverse range of topics
where the central Focus was on machine
learning and these topics range from
infectious disease metabolic disorder
Neuroscience psychiatric disorder
oncology and so so all of these projects
are presently visible on the
omexological important which I showed
you just uh well I was explaining about
navigating into the portal
and these projects can also be showcased
for higher studies and International
University applications like the more
for research videos did for example
dilara Daikin who got accepted to the
erasmendous imbrc program after
completing the research project and
group mehra he got activated to the
Precision medicine and graduate program
at Manchester University and Anusha who
got who recently got accepted to a
metagenomics PhD program in University
in Sweden and faculties and researchers
have also collaborated through our
programs to publish their research work
and our latest collaboration has been
with a team of researchers at noguchi
Memorial Institute for medical research
at the University of Ghana to carry out
a computational based study to
understand the variants associated with
sulfur toxin resistance in plasmodium
and it's just not limited to Scientific
related outcomes it is also possible to
pursue an entrepreneurship and business
Innovation track that for example like a
team of industrial researchers from
biologic Support Services a
biotechnology company in nitricated
their aim was to improve the fertility
of women in Nigeria and improve their
chances of carrying their babies to term
by developing a test kit so as part of
it they carried out a metal a
metagenomics research project
and the entrepreneurship trackers not
only pursued by researchers but by
students as well for instance a group of
students from undergraduate and
postgraduate program from vit they
worked on developing an early detection
kit of neurological disorders with with
a specific focus on Alzheimer's disease
so all of these are just very
inspirational research projects that
have been carried out from a diverse
range of by students from a diverse
range of background or a diverse range
of struggle so organic can be explored
and carried out by all of us uh just
like these students so that is all about
that I wanted to talk about in this
presentation so now to learn more about
the research fellowship program I would
like to pass on the stage to my
colleague Miss Pastor who will be
explaining about how you can enroll for
the program uh what is the registration
process and how it is kept so overdue
thank you so much uh SRI gauri and uh it
was a very wonderful presentation or
just Leanne shubham thank you for
explaining uh about your research
project in uh in a brief and crisp
manner so let me share my screen and uh
guide you all through the first the
different type of specialization tracks
which we have and uh on which you all
can work on depending upon your research
interest so as a SRI gauri explained in
uh the beginning that this like the
research fellowship program has been
designed for the young researchers for
biotechnologists for biologists who want
to take advantage of the bioinformatics
resources for analysis of complex life
science data and become well versed in
bioinformatics so this is the right
place and this is the right program in
which you can enroll at further carry
out the analysis so
in omic's logic so what we offer so omix
logic offers high grade training and
research tools for Hands-On analysis for
various research fields which include
analysis of Big Data belonging to
multi-atomic data multi-amic fields like
genomics like transcriptomics like
epigenomics and metagenomics then there
are further research specialization
tracks for omics data analysis like
infectious diseases which you can see on
my screen Precision medicine Precision
oncology then neurosciences space omics
metabolic disorders agree bioinformatics
Immunology cheminformatics
Etc we also aim to utilize data science
techniques programming languages like R
and python for bioinformatics then some
machine learning methods bioinformatics
tools and softwares and AI Based
training platform that is the T by info
platform of which
you might have seen in the presentation
of justice and show them the pipelines
Etc they ran and so this is a platform
which is being you know designed by the
topper bioinformatics Research Center
Israel
so now what I'll show you so here are
some like the the below are some listed
here on my screen are some listed areas
of research for various fields that
omics logic mentors are working on and
are open for all to carry out
independent on group research projects
and able to go forward for a publication
in their perspective or respective
Fields so the very first specialization
track is the infectious diseases and
here below are the mention oming data
analysis in which one can work on so if
we talk about genomic data analysis so
we have listed out few of the uh
experimental design on which you can
work on so first is comparing DNA
sequencing using phylogenetic analysis
MSA that is multiple sequence alignment
you can visualize and fill and filtering
alignments then uh for the uh then the
second is the transcriptomic data
analysis where you can identify the
signature significantly different under
therapeutic drug treatment and untreated
conditions also
then for the epigenomics data analysis
DNA methylation analysis DNA protein
interaction analysis then for
metagenomic data analysis you can
analyze the microbiome of data and
species diversity you can determine the
relationship between different
communities Etc so here are some project
examples which we have listed on
infectious diseases and when you'll
click on these uh project images you
will be redirected to the a respected uh
respected research project so one is on
SARS scope to genomics again at the next
is on malaria infection then sf9 cells
biologics Ebola virus epidemic Etc
so the next specialization track on
which we are working on oncology and
it's right now in quite uh you know it's
trending it's in hype and below are the
listed omics data analysis in which one
can work on so the first is
transcriptomic data analysis uh where
you can you know where you can do
Downstream analysis of transcriptomic
data visualize two statistic analysis of
differentially expressed Gene
identification of transcriptomic
signatures when it comes to machine
learning model you can use regression
and factor a regression analysis you can
identify feature importance and
interpretable ml modeling then we have
genomic data analysis we can integrate
multiomics integration also
um where in uh where we can integrate
multiomics data to maximize information
content to study cancer biology then we
can uh you know work on epigenome data
analysis DNA methylation analysis DNA
protein interaction analysis sources
then there is another aspect that is
structural biology and cheminformatics
so when it comes to structural biology
and common cheminformatics we will be
understanding the protein structural
analysis structural functional
implications of prominent genomic
variants how we can explore gamma
informatics strategy so as to model and
screen uh and to improve the drug
Discovery results exploring small
molecules Library based on structural
similarity for candidate lead generation
and then comparing and contrasting their
effectiveness through molecular docking
and investigation
so again here are some project examples
which have been listed below for
oncology that is cancer macrophages tcga
liver cancer risk PDX tumor
microenvironment Etc
and the third specialization track in
which one can work is precision medicine
so in Precision medicine you can work on
transcriptomic data analysis clinical
data analysis epigenomic genomic data
analysis and this is the example this is
the uh example research project which we
have uploaded on omix logic learn portal
and if you can click on you will have a
glimpse of the what all steps or what
the strategy which we have followed so
as to complete the research project
and the next one is the agree
bioinformatics so in agree by
informatics we can analyze genomic data
we can analyze metagenomic as well as
transcriptomic data so we can study how
distant genetic profiles are associated
with the condition for example drought
resistance and there is a Associated
example research project to it that is
potato drought resistance gene
expression of uh drought stress then
when it comes to metagenomic data
analysis we can analyze the microbiome
composition and species diversity we can
uh we can see the processing of 16 as
rrna data we can visualize the
otu's operational taxonomic units
abundance tables can be seen for
diversities we can explore species
richness through phylogenetic analysis
Etc and then in transcriptomic data
analysis we can again identify gene
expression levels interpreting results
using statistical methods such as P
values false Discovery rates Etc
so on moving ahead then we have
neurosciences so in neurosciences again
a transcriptomic data could be analyzed
so uh what we can uh do is we can
identify variability in differential
expressed genes across the data set and
there is a example data sets in projects
which have been linked over here you can
definitely open up this link and go
through with it and then we have an
Associated example research project
again on the loan portal which is a
Alzheimer's disease patient pathology
differentially expressed genes in
Pathways so you can take a full-fledged
comprehensive look on This research
project that how it is how we have done
it how are all mixed logic mentors and
team have a completed and published it
on our portal then next is metabolic
disorders where uh where mainly we are
working on diabetes and in this we have
we are you know working on
transcriptomic data analysis we are
basically comparing the kidney
transcriptomic profiles for early and
advanced diabetic nephropathy which
reveals potential new mechanism for
disease progression and then finding RNA
genes differentially regulated between
the two conditions in order to identify
the novel Target so as to find the
uh the Cure the treatment for the then
the space or mix again it is uh we can
analyze the data in transcriptomic then
epigenomic metagenomics and uh today you
have already learned and you can you
have already heard ojasvian shubham
explaining about the altogether new
ohmic field that is space omics and
these are below and below mentioned are
the data analysis types uh which you can
work on so transcript Atomic data is
where they can you know find a
differentially expressed genes looking
for significant altered Pathways then
analyze of rnac data of organisms such
as mice uh zebrafish microbes Etc then
it comes to epigenomics data analysis
then again we can talk about the
bisulfide C the chip seek data organism
in space studying about their epigenetic
changes in gut microbiome Etc and then
taking a look at the essential Pathways
such as w dp53 and DNA damage response
so these were the specialization tracks
which we are working on so these all
specialization track can be integrated
with uh you know machine learning aspect
or any of the program programming
languages like r or python for the for
the interpretation for the novel Finding
so
when I scroll down you can see here the
research projects of our research
fellows and these all research projects
are are on different specialization
areas for example some are on oncology
some is on a space or mix Amazon
neurosciences some is on Precision
medicine
Etc
so you can take a thorough look on this
page and uh you can decide in which
particular research area you are
interested in and how you would like to
take it further and develop your own
independent research project and then
publish into a research publication in a
good peer-reviewed research Journal so
here are the glimpse of our some expert
talks related to different
specialization tracks which you can see
and it's available on our YouTube
channel as well so it is again on
different specialization track for
example the first one is on omics in
virology so it is given by Dr Rahul
which is a professor in Department of
microbiology and Immunology from
University of California then we have a
very good talk on molecular and cell
biology and immunopathogenesis of Corona
viruses from Dr Gus costellis he's a
president of Napier USA then again a
mathematical modeling of the single
strike 100 RNA virus by Dr Leonard
Broski who is director of topper
bioinformatics Resource Center Israel
and then again a talk on omix virology
system medicine interpretable machine
learning model for precision oncology
and so on so uh like there are there are
multiple options for you to take a look
on and decide in which particular
specialization track you are interested
and how you would like to integrate uh
maybe our program our programming Python
Programming data science machine
learning aspects with all of these
specialization track and come up with
the research idea so now uh you must be
you know thinking how you can enroll in
research fellowship program what is the
program structure what are the different
resources which one could have access to
and then the fee so um
to explain so This research fellowship
program you know it's it's divided into
three phases or we can say three stages
and the three stages are the first stage
is to train you so the first stage is
training part the second stage is your
analysis part where you need to you know
find an impactful research topic
properly prepare a methodology which you
will following so as to come up with the
results part and the third stage is to
present your analysis so as to get the
expert feedback so when it comes to
training we will be training you
according to your research interest we
will be quantifying your skills in omics
data analysis processing and
visualization and interpretation things
so uh for example you are interested in
genomics we will be you know um we will
be providing you with that kind of
material which will increase your
theoretical as well as conceptual
knowledge related to genomic data
analysis so so uh some of the topics
which we'll be covering in the training
uh stage would be introduction to
bioinformatics and basics of data in
life sciences so that you will get a
glimpse of what is bioinformatics what
are the basic terminologies which we'll
be using in bioinformatics how
bioinformatics can be used in healthcare
industry how bioinformatics is
transforming translational research Etc
and then there would be some lessons on
basic uh basics of data in life science
like what is central dogma what is uh
transcriptomics what is uh genomics what
is meta genomics what is epigenomics
proteomics ETC so these all data types
omics data types would also be covered
then data science and machine learning
for non-engineers and biologists
and then R and Python Programming and
any depth analytics for complex omics
data so these all topics we'll be
covering again uh we'll be covering
those we will be covering according to
your research interest so as I said if
someone is interested in any of the
ohmic data data type so we'll be
focusing uh we will be providing that
material that particular resources so
that they get uh they have enough
material so as to increase their
conceptual and theoretical knowledge
which will eventually help them out so
as to you know find an impactful
research topic to do proper literature
review to do a proper you know find out
a proper data set on which they can work
on prepare their full methodology and
then do the analysis and interpretation
afterwards so the second stage is find
an impactful research topic where you
will learn to perform literature review
and plan out your project
so there are few steps few points which
you need to keep in mind when you are in
second stage of your research fellowship
program the first one is to make sure
your that your research question is
compelling to those already in the field
so obviously you will be you know uh you
will be doing uh performing some
literature review and you will come up
with uh some papers which will uh you
know Fascinate you and you want to do
some kind of similar work but obviously
those who have already done on that
particular same topic so you have you
are not working on a noble uh finding so
it's almost similar so you need to be
extraordinary your research question
needs to be more compelling than those
who are already in the field then the
second is set specific parameters to
answer the research question
conclusively
Methodist find data sets that fit your
objectives and explore them for batch
effects or bias get feedback from our
expert mentors on your topic and
Analysis proposal so whatever data set
you will finalize whatever literature a
review you will be doing whatever method
methodology which you'll prepare uh to
you know
analyze your data set to do the
interpretation to get the results Etc
these all these all steps would be
Mentor guided so our expert mentors
would be there to guide you on each and
every step so that you come up on a
proper and constructive conclusion now
the third step is present your analysis
for expert feedback so you need to
develop a complete project ready for
expert review and feedback so once your
project is prepared it becomes the proof
that you have understood the topic and
analyzed data correctly expert feedback
and peer review will identify gaps and
omissions you can address before sharing
the final results with the scientific
community and the world so once your
project is done you need to jot it down
in a proper menu script a scientific
manuscript and do the editings
so that is done by the expert feedback
and our mentors will eventually help you
out in uh those like in correcting your
mistakes in your writing patterns and
they'll identify those gaps and will
fill up those voids and after your
research project is done and what are
the potential outcomes so one of the
potential outcome is expert feedback and
overall evaluation of your project
quality Innovation and Analysis
execution
second is the poster presentation at the
research fellowship meeting or a
research symposium so this month on 30
and 31st we are organizing a research
Symposium and we are inviting each and
every participant out there
if they have done any of like if they
have done any research project with
their pis or with their faculty or their
University or colleges they can come and
they can present their work on uh in
omics research Symposium in the poster
presentation competition and win some
exciting cash prizes also
those who are interested they can ping
their email address in the chat box and
we'll convey and we provide you with the
details of the poster presentation
competition and research Symposium as
well
now the third is path to collaboration
with expert mentors or faculty at the
partner universities and then the last
one is path to a full publication so you
can get your research paper
published also as SRI gauri has given
you a number of example in her
presentation of those who have already
published their paper and those who are
working on getting their paper published
their research paper their research work
published so definitely there is a path
to a full publication now these are this
was a Structure which we will follow now
coming up on the tenures and the
resources so there are four different
tenures in which one can join one is 45
days 60 days 90 days and then there is
another one that is 180 days that is six
months then we have some we have common
resources for all the 14 years that is
asynchronous courses Hands-On
assignments group sessions program
course access omix logic program access
educational Cloud pipelines Online
technical support online mental support
then if you get stuck somewhere there is
an option of one-on-one Mentor guidance
as well
so these are the resources which are
common in all the tenures but there are
outcomes there is difference between the
outcomes so if you'll enroll for 45 days
the outcome is a literature review and a
intermediate level of project with the
project report
then in 60 days you are applicable for a
literature review intermediate level of
analysis then uh and a project report
for that intermediate level of analysis
and then if it's ready you can present
in a research or you can present in
research Symposium as well
in 90 days there would be a full-fledged
research project
and this particular project would be you
know applicable for the research paper
publication as well and similar for the
180 days also
so these are some resources outcomes
under 10 years which one can uh
take a look and then when you scroll
down you will find there are three
different payment checkout links for
research fellowship program 45 days 60
days 90 days and 180 days
so if you'll click on this button you'll
be redirected to the payment page and we
are you know providing scholarship to
low-income countries so you can reach
out to us at marketing at the rate
omixtlogic.com or you can directly
connect with us at uh plus
919876-134120 this is the official
contact number and it's active on
WhatsApp uh maybe uh shrigori or shubham
can share the details in the chat so
that those whosoever is interested they
can directly ping us or mail US mail us
at marketing at the rate by
omixelogic.com so one thing I would like
to clear here we have different uh
prizes for different communities for
example uh there are pricing uh for in
that there is different pricing for
Indian Community that's in INR there is
different pricing for African Community
that's naira then for USA it's different
and so on so for that um
could you please share the uh learn
portal Link in the chat box and uh those
who are interested they can take a look
so this was
yeah so this was all about the payment
checkout the research sources uh the
outcomes the program structure Etc and
if anyone is having any doubt regarding
specialization tracks or the enrollment
process Etc please feel free to Ping in
the chat box and I'll be there to guide
and assist you thank you so much and
over to you SRI gauri
all right thank you so much
let's share the page for enrolling
all right I've shared the portal link
for registering for the program so does
the participants have any queries uh one
participant has interested or has
expressed their interest in
participating for the poster
presentation
uh perfect so could you please share
your email address in the chat box uh
we'll be sending you the mail okay so
you have already shared uh sure Vijay
sharma152@gmail.com we'll be sharing the
necessary details with you over your
mail address
thank you for sharing
thank you so much
so we'll pause for a couple of seconds
for the participants to share their
queries
and if you have no queries you'll be
ending it just
a couple of minutes
uh all right so we do have one query
what is the scope of NGS and
bioinformatics
[Music]
all right uh obviously has shared that
Russell is requesting for Fellowship
scholarship
uh Russell I guess uh one of our
representative uh shubham Kumar is
already in touch with you
so you uh will definitely get back to
you and will clarify all your doubts if
you have any thank you so much
foreign
we have another query from sansida uh is
it really possible to publish an
original paper
uh yes uh sanjada it is possible to
publish an original paper but obviously
it takes uh it takes time uh because uh
when it comes to publishing a paper
there are a few protocols which we need
to follow and uh like obviously you
cannot publish a research you cannot
publish a research project which is
being completed in 45 or 60 days at
least you require three months or six
months of a project work and then
um a full-fledged good manuscript and
then there is a
okay so just fee has already and say yes
it is possible you have just to find
some more key findings from analysis
which is not there in the authors or
digital world thank you Jesse
all right I hope that answers your
queries under the
uh she wants to know who will help her
or will collaborate with her
so our expert mentors will help her out
and collaborate with her uh so sanjita
you can mail us and we can maybe meet a
one-on-one on a separate Zoom call and
clarify all your doubts there
all right thank you so much please share
your email ID as a personal chat so that
we can reach out
and we have another query I have worked
on identification of candidate genes in
melanoma skin cancer using differential
gene expression and co-expression
network analysis and how can I get the
ontology
so I guess I have to unmute myself so we
have different pipelines on the server
which uh gives the results for both
egg and jio Analysis also on ncbi I
guess and we have that
pipeline build if the data set is
with analysis of uh
the GAC and gu based engagement analysis
so on the server we have those pipelines
preview